[Music]
oh well if you're on the payroll it's
easy to say it works isn't it but
actually out there in the real world
there is not a european demos there is
not a european identity
maybe
but maybe
there may be one exception there may be
one exception and that could be belgium
because nobody ever dares tell the truth
about belgium
belgium is not a nation
belgium
it's one of the most fascinating
countries in europe
it's a country where some of its biggest
political parties are explicitly
anti-belgium where parties of the same
political color are completely divided
by virtue of language and culture alone
a country where public funding for
political parties is some of the highest
in the eu and it's a country where its
political divides serve as one of the
strongest analogies for the divisions
facing europe as a whole
belgium is a federal state that has to
constantly struggle with balancing the
dutch-speaking flemings the
french-speaking wolons and also a
smaller german-speaking minority
the federal government distributes power
between two parliaments a judiciary and
an executive branch where language has
to be accounted for at every single step
the executive the constitutional court
and the chamber of representatives are
all equally or proportionally split
between the different language groups
and in belgium national parties do not
exist they represent some ideology but
what's more relevant is they're split by
language when you examine below the
federal government all three language
groups have their own distinct
unicameral legislatures that each have
their own executives and the legitimacy
of these communities is entirely based
on language
however what complicates things is that
there are also regions which also have
their own parliaments and executives and
regions are not based on language and
just have more generic state powers like
management of public transport the
economy and employment
for example flanders is a community a
government based off of a culture with
its own common language but it is also a
region with generic state powers in
contrast brussels is a region with its
own specific economic policies but it is
not a community brussels has to balance
both a french and dutch-speaking
population either way region or
community in belgium the divides they're
real on the federal level the two
largest flemish parties have been
separated into the opposition and
regional governments are almost
exclusively culturally focused the
flemish independence movement is the
largest party in the flemish regional
government bar none and the largest
political party in wallonia ps is almost
exclusively bolonian in the media sector
each community has their own set of
public platforms be it radio television
newspapers or magazines
an education where flemish students are
considered some of the best in europe
with significantly higher reading
mathematics and science skills the
walonian education system is below the
european average and in some cases
french parents in the brussels region
will send their children to flemish
schools as opposed to french-speaking
ones for that reason alone
in regards to politics and economics
flanders is also often seen as a
creditor while wallonia is often
characterized as a debtor and in the
21st century flanders has been typically
closer to balancing its budget and has
also had less debt where wallonia
unfortunately has had both a higher
level of debt while also controlling a
significantly lower share of national
gdp and employment
it's pretty standard knowledge among
europeans that the distribution of power
between the walloons and fleming's
wasn't always this way where wallonia
used to receive massive amounts of
revenue after the industrial revolution
through its steel industry and flanders
was historically poor and had a larger
textile and agricultural sector and was
also subjugated by the french-speaking
elite this dynamic essentially flipped
as the flemish city antwerp grew in
value as a seaport in the early 20th
century
also where socialist leading policies
have typically flourished in maloney and
industrial areas the flemish countryside
has overwhelmingly voted more
conservative and catholic the biggest
unions farmers organizations and also
health insurance and flanders as
catholic while it is mainly state
regulated in wallonia
this is also visible in the flanders
rural landscape where houses are built
seemingly random because for years the
catholic party incentivized laborers
that worked in industrialized cities to
actually remain in the countryside by
constructing homes in the middle of
nowhere which is obviously very
expensive just for the sake of trying to
prevent flemings from building a
socialist identity in industrialized
cities today a flemish independence
party is the largest party in flanders
although the flemish independence
movement was historically taboo the
world wars allowed the germans to seduce
a section of the flemish independence
movement by offering an independent
flemish nation within the german empire
in world war 1 the germans who were
occupying belgium conducted flamin
politique and rule and divide exploiting
a fraction of the flemish independence
movement by establishing the first dutch
university in kent and also by making
the university of kent dutch speaking
when dutch wasn't even considered as a
potential option for a research language
in 1968 at the university of lovin
flemish students and professors kicked
out the french-speaking section of its
university while the french speakers
built new love in a french-speaking
university 15 kilometers away in malonia
since then state reforms have been
incremental but significant very complex
expensive and hard each giving more
responsibility to the regions and
communities and less to the belgian
federal government
[Music]
take a northern western european country
and compare it with a southern one and
you should be able to make a couple of
sound generalizations about these
countries just by looking at the
differences between the north and south
of belgium like belgium the north of
europe is more dependent on services and
trade and has recently had a stronger
economy while the south is more
dependent on industry tourism and is
considered by some metrics economically
weaker being more likely to suffer from
economic shocks than its northern
counterparts
like belgium there is an important
difference which does matter between
roman and germanic culture and like
belgium where consensus literally takes
the longest on the planet the eu also
has extreme difficulty with balancing
european countries in order to get even
something close to uniminity
finally like belgium europe is also
uncertain about what it's going to do
with itself in the future
[Music]